feminists really liked the book right up
until the last chapter on marriage and
conservatives really like the marriage
chapter let's just tear the book between
the two groups and then everyone's happy
everyone's happy
[Applause]
hello and welcome to women balls where I
K tables speak today's Trailblazers my
guess this week is a writer and
campaigner whose recent book a case
against the sexual Revolution offers a
new Guide to Sex in the 21st century
porn is to sex as McDonald's is to food
seen by some as conservative feminist
thinking it was described by the
guardian as one of the most important
feminist books of its time Rylan Herald
the sexual Revolution as a good thing
for women everywhere she argues that
these freedoms have actually led to
problems you don't exactly have this
kind of service at home she is piled
into multiple feminist debates voicing
her gender critical views why she
believes marriage is good for women and
why it's time to turn back the clock on
sex pornography and prostitution as a
campaigner my guest became a press
officer for the campaign group we can't
consent to this Which documents cases
for women have been killed in rough sex
in 2022 she co-founded a think tank the
other half a non-partisan organization
that Champions the voices of women and
families not heard in Westminster
currently seen as carving at her own
counter-feminist movement she believes
where Beyonce goes we all follow
that's a credit to spectator TV let's
take for example Beyonce or a great
feminist icon where Beyonce goes I
suppose we all follow if you like it you
should have put a ring on it my guest
today is Louise Perry hello
um so thanks for coming on this podcast
today
um we always begin by asking what I have
been told in the past is a loaded
question which is would you describe
yours as a happy childhood
yeah I think I would yeah
um and not only because my parents will
watch it though they probably will
um uh yeah I mean also very boring I
often get
I always feel like I'm really
shortchanging people when I'm asked to
talk about my upbringing because it's so
extremely conventional I grew up in
London
um I guess the only thing that's
interesting is that I come from like an
extremely Guardian reading
sort of background
um at one point we've got two Guardians
a day I really just just because it had
to go around or because my dad took one
to work
and then I would take part of it to
school and my mum would keep the rest
which sections would you go for GT do
you remember the days this was Alan Ross
Bridger Berliner kind of era of the
Guardian
um whereas now my parents only get the
garden at the weekend so
make of that what you will so that's
that's kind of the only like thing
that's interesting I suppose in the
sense that I've now
um I mean I don't know a bit reluctant
to call myself a conservative but a lot
of other people do
um you said from the age of 11 you were
listening to radio 4.
um so remember saying that but it is
true yeah come on maybe someone just
found it out I've read it online
um so if we're thinking about Guardian
two Guardians a day radio four moral
maze yeah yeah were you very aware of
current affairs and politics early on or
what was that oh yeah usually I've
always been a News Junkie yeah and did
you end up having I suppose lots of
discussions with your parents around the
dinner table about things like this did
they encourage it
yeah very much so I mean I have since
become
um I guess a shade more conservative
than my parents but not that not hugely
so we don't disagree on anything really
substantial but yeah it was a very um
very like discoursy breakfast table
and your only child no I have a younger
brother okay
so it all went debates
um and then I was going to ask you I
mean you want to study at University
anthropology and women's studies and of
course we're here today because of the
book you have at what point I suppose
were you thinking about gender
um in terms of growing up when you
decided to obviously go and study
women's studies and
[Music]
so I don't write about this this in the
book deliberately although I have
written about it elsewhere I
the trans issue was quite formative for
me in the sense that I was a um soas
School of Oriental African studies at
the time which is an extremely
left wing University I actually wrote a
piece about it for The Spectator years
and years ago
um if anyone wants to dig that or not
um and
I kind of privately came to the
conclusion that the
trans activism as it was I mean this was
in the days when really the only person
who was talking about this was Julie
Bendel like it was completely impossible
to say anything critical to trans
activism in public
um and I decided privately that the
whole thing was
insane
and that for me was like quite an
important moment in terms of
being willing to believe things that no
one around me
believed
I guess even if only privately yeah and
were you having conversations with
people about the time on just not really
no not really at all so
um I mean I I now kind of make no
pretense of
thinking anything else but um
yeah that I think that was I mean for me
I think the reason that that was
important was because
it was that moment of like hang on if
this thing if progressives are wrong
about this thing what else might they be
wrong about
and even though it took quite a few
years for me to then conclude you know
that the sexual Revolution was actually
somewhat terrible for instance
um I think that that was the first
Domino
and during this period are you I suppose
like
thinking of the teacher this is what a
feminist looks like but are you
describing yourself as a feminist yeah
so I was I I mean so I I initially was
drawn to radical feminism
um because that was
um
that was the group of women who were
being who were critical of the excesses
of trans activism
um like Julie in fact who I I who I
first met at this stage in my life
um and so radical journalism was kind of
the obvious thing to go and read about
it was the it was the obvious counter to
the mainstream
um and I'm still good friends of radical
feminism and sort of we we've reached
many of the same conclusions on all
sorts of issues like porn prostitution
whatever but
um I don't I don't subscribe to the
belief system anymore
and after University you went to work in
a Rape Crisis Center what led you to do
that
well I was volunteering there at the
time when I was studying and then
um a job came up so it was it was
slightly coincidental in that sense
because it was just like a natural thing
to go and do once I finished studying
um and also because
I felt strongly about it and it's you
know it's good important work I almost
stayed in the charity sector that was
that was my that was my alternative life
course that I would have just worked in
Charities for
for years
I ended up being a journalist slightly
accidentally
and why did you leave the charity sector
then if it was potentially
the long time route I just didn't like
the work culture there I mean I'm not
I guess
maybe not coincidentally given all the
sort of controversial stuff I write
about I'm not I don't really like
I'm not a very good Joiner in her
if that makes sense like I don't I I I I
find it I I find it really grating to
have to sort of tow ideological lines
and you do have to do that in
a lot of sectors and definitely the
charity sector
um so I wanted to say you're for views
or yeah
um be very
conformist in all sorts of different
ways one of the reasons I didn't want to
stay at the organization I was at is
that the there was a move to it would
have been women only for years and years
and there was a move to
to allow men to use the service as well
um which I just thought was a really
stupid idea and because for the because
of the risk to abuses of the service and
stuff like that and I yeah I just sort
of grew tired of having to
um play off as politics and so on so and
you mentioned obviously the move to
journalism but were you always writing
growing up or or getting into debates
for people or was it more I suppose um
introspective uh I was extremely
insufferable but there was somebody
um and I'd yeah I was like a school
debater and all this kind of stuff but I
am
I didn't
um I did always sort of privately hope
that one day I might I might make a
living as a writer or might be a writer
but I would never say so to anyone it
was like the most if I felt like it was
the most embarrassing thing to admit
because it seemed such an unrealistic
thing to want to do
so privately yeah but I would never have
dreamed that I'd now be making a living
doing this
um now for our listeners on a small
portion of course you don't know about
your writing and I wanted just to begin
could you I suppose uh you've talked
about radical feminism where do you
align as a feminist name how would you
explain it to someone oh I don't know I
don't know what the name is I mean the
uh so some people would say I'm a
conservative feminist
um post-liberal feminist is another term
um uh Kathleen stock who wrote the
forward for my book she she talks about
materialist feminism which I quite like
what does that mean well it's a bit too
academic isn't it that's a problem with
that term but um
basically starting from the recognition
that men and women are really profoundly
different
in important ways and that any kind of
feminist politics has to has to
negotiate those differences rather than
trying to erase them I'd say would be
that the crucial distinction between
um
what I'm now trying to do and
other forms of feminism not all but you
know the mainstream view
um
Mary Harrington he's a friend of mine
she um she she calls it reactionary
feminism which is like kind of a joke
but also kind of not a joke it's
actually quite good
kind of sticks so I don't know I think
it's not up to me to describe exactly
what it is because I don't think I get a
choice in the matter but um
yeah I mean I end up
I start with feminist prayers basically
and I end up at some conservative
conclusions like I am pro-marriage for
instance which is a which is a really
unusual position
that
um we've touched on your book very
lightly um the case against the sexual
revolution could you I suppose could you
just start by telling me what is uh sex
positivity and what is case against it
uh so the the the kind of generous
description of it is that it's um
uh uh about
challenging
old-fashioned ideas
around sex which are sort of needlessly
distressing
to people you know saying that actually
there isn't any reason to be ashamed of
perfectly benign things like
I don't know masturbation or same-sex
relationships or whatever you know
whatever you want to call it and um and
particularly about women sort of
reclaiming their own sexuality and not
being you know like that there is a
there is a completely
um
benign and persuasive version of sex
positive feminism I don't have a problem
with the problem I think is that in
practice what's sex positive feminism
ends up doing is making excuses for
um a kind of sexual culture which
actually favors male preferences not
female and encouraging women to imitate
male sexuality in a way that is actually
really harmful to women
and do you think that goes back so that
the problem with the sexual Revolution
is that it paved the way for this rather
than more in women's terms or well I
think what the sexual Revolution did is
well I mean sort of two things right so
there's the material Dimension to the
such Revolution which is the which is
the pill which is the The crucial
innovation
to my mind it's this massive technology
shock which suddenly allows women to
control their reproduction in a way
they've never had done before is why we
call it the pill capital P you know like
is that big a deal
so there's that there's also the
ideological stuff that comes with it
because this is all happening at the
same time as the
um
the rejection of Christianity really is
I think what we should be that's what
actually happens in the 60s right which
but there are so many other ways in
which we talk about it but I think
it is
it should almost be understood you know
some historians now are starting to
think of it as being almost like a
second Reformation you know that level
of ideological break with the past
where everything associated with
tradition which means any association of
Christianity
has to be questioned thrown out the
window Etc including when it comes to
sexual ethics so we end up in a
situation where
um any kind of limitations on freedom
are up for contestation and the only
framework or or sort of ethical system
left standing is the consent one you say
as long as everyone's consenting
and is able to consent there's no
problem and all other Norms would ever
have to go out the window
and I think what
you know having seen that played out now
for more than half a century
what what ended up happening is a drift
back
towards a system of sexual ethics which
favors
men
a minority of men I don't think that
this is like all men having a marvelous
time for such Revolution they're clearly
not like it's not it's not nice to be
like stuck in your mum's basement
watching porn or whatever like miserable
outcome many men are experiencing
um it's a minority of men who are I
describe him in the book as the Hugh
Hefner's of the world the guys who are
really attractive
love being promiscuous love having
consequence free sex obviously love the
pill obviously love the decrimination of
abortion like like the whole sort of
supposedly sex positive culture hugely
serves their interests
and they're able to basically just
consume women in the way that you would
consume any sort of like
any any commodity
um
and I would say that that Triumph of the
Hugh Hefner's has been falsely
represented as a as a feminist victory
when it is nothing of the sort
so when I suppose you're looking at the
sexual Revolution and we're talking a
bit about objection Christian values say
but also the Pearl do you see some
positive developments in that yeah this
is some of the things that just sprung
from that later down the line that are
problematic yeah absolutely I mean
I I have a kind of
I have complex feelings towards
Christians such as ethics right because
there are ways in and looking at the
really long sweep of History here right
I think there's this popular narrative
which I really want to challenge which
is basically that
putting it really crudely up until up
until five minutes ago all of our
ancestors were just really sort of
stupid and ignorant and and malign and
people just suddenly woke up in the
1960s and decided we've been doing it
all wrong and now you know like now
we're on the like Long March towards
Progressive Triumph I think that's I
think that's nonsense I think the most
of what's
changed
women's lives everyone's lives has been
to do with technology has been super
material change the fact that our
economy is wildly different than it used
to be you know women can participate in
public life in ways that we couldn't
previously partly because of things like
washing machines and tampons and do you
know what I mean like the the story has
so much more to do with the
practicalities of day-to-day life than
it has to do with ideology although
there is the ideological
current as well
and
if you look at like the whole long sweep
of of sexual ethics and look at you know
don't just think about the 1950s versus
that I get so annoying people back to
the 1950s whatever like as if the world
didn't exist before the 1950s which is
actually a very peculiar decade
um
you know when Christian sexual ethics
arrive in the Roman World they are it's
incredibly radical right the idea that
men should not have unquestioned access
to prostitutes for instance in a slave
Society where buying sex is incredibly
cheap the idea that high status Roman
men shouldn't be sexually abusing their
slaves and their social inferiors you
know
this is the kind of thing that Christian
sexual ethics arose to challenge
and should be understood as a first
sexual revolution in that sense and was
very much in many ways in women's
interests and the reason that early many
early Christians were women
and the reason that Nietzsche described
Christianity as a religion of women and
slaves is because it did serve women's
interests in all sorts of important ways
in challenging that kind of
so I write in the book about the fact
that male and female sexuality are
should kind of be understood as two bell
curves in terms of interest in having
casual sex buying sex whatever all the
kind of um the trait that psychologists
call sociosexuality
men are higher towards the social like
the higher end of the sociosexuality
scale than women are with with plenty of
overlap
what the first sexual revolution of the
first century should be understood as
doing is basically
obliging men to match the female
bell curve if that makes sense like for
you have to be monogamous you have to
you can't have extramarital sex you
can't you know you can't buy sex all of
this stuff is all to do with
encouraging men to behave more like
women whereas our sexual revolution has
been doing the opposite is encouraging
women to behave more like men
and I think for all of the
for all of the downsides of the
Christian system which include you know
the fact that
women end up being shamed publicly for
not being chased the fact that
Christians have quite weird ideas about
the unborn child like most cultures are
much more relaxed about abortion than
Christians are right all of that stuff
has all sorts of negative repercussions
for women and I think that there have
been we definitely reap benefits from
having thrown that system out at the
same time
I almost think of what's Happening Now
is almost reverting to a more
Roman system if that makes sense right
we're actually the high status men have
basically can do what they want you know
they've got Tinder they've got the whole
world of the sex industry freely
available to them and so on I think that
what I'm trying to what the argument I'm
trying to make in the book is that there
have been
trade-offs and some of those trade-offs
are really really painful
do you find it's quite an unfashionable
argument to make amongst some of your
friends or or How does it go down have
you been accused and I didn't feel like
you know Serena Joy type figure
I can try to push me back to the fifth
did you get much of that no one's
explicitly accusing me being Serena Joy
but
um
uh not as much as you think yeah but I
mean a bit yeah
um I got
when I was doing week on consent to this
stuff and talking and like talking about
things like
um why choking is not a good
like sexual fashion
um I I get caught vanilla and prude on
Twitter but that's just Twitter
um in general
no it's been like 95 positive so much
more than I thought I thought I might
get wrecked over the coals a bit for
this book but no and have you had people
get in touch and having read the book in
old movie say Chimes actually perhaps
all the time several times a day
yeah it's amazing lots of people say
um
something like I've thought this
privately all this time
and I didn't really feel like I could
say publicly
which is nice
um you had a piece in the mail which I
think and obviously I'm a journalist no
one gets to pick the headlines
but had they had to get married and do
your best to stay married yeah and so if
I was not to judge too much in reaction
things but
how does that meet I think what people
say to that because obviously it's
become quite fashionable in a way to
almost
I think marriages
are too traditional to in the past it
limits women it what's the reaction mean
like to that
generally the reaction is that
um feminists really like the book right
up until the last chapter on marriage
and conservatives really like the
marriage chapter and then have more
misgivings about
the other bits of it
um
I mean what I what just let's just tear
the book between the two groups and then
everyone's happy everyone's happy
um and
I mean the argument that I'm making for
marriage is not one it's not coming from
religious principles it's not coming
from just this is tradition therefore
it's good sort of principles it's I try
and make it a very kind of data driven
argument which is that there are all
sorts of ways in which
um married people fare better you know
um financially
socially health-wise whatever
particularly children do so much better
in households where both parents are
there we know that married people are
less likely to break up the non-marri
people
etc etc comparing cultures where
um polygamous cultures for instance
versus monogamous cultures which are
which are the only two options by the
way there's no like fantasy land where
women have loads of husbands in there
and they're loving it right that the
options you have to choose from are
basically those two
um
and seeing that the monogamous cultures
do better on all sorts of metrics
including things like lower domestic
violence rates lower child abuse rates
you know there's a there's a really
really strong argument to be made just
from the numbers that
people feel better
when marriage is the norm and abandoning
it as a norm
has I mean
I completely can see that there are some
marriages that really do need to end and
the domestic violence you know it is is
clearly a terrible thing when women are
trapped in in marriages with violent
husbands and they can't get out legally
it's also worth bearing in mind that
women who are unmarried are actually
much more at risk of domestic violence
than women who are married now it's like
the relationship is really not that
close
and the downside of having
the loss of the loss of the institution
has overwhelmingly been born by mothers
and children
and I think
the thing that I'm accused of sometimes
by some feminist including feminist
friends is being defeatist
and kind of
not
not wanting to just completely overhaul
masculinity and feminine feminine she
has such and and
seeking out the kind of pragmatic
compromise positions like for instance
yes marriage has all these all these
problems all these trade-offs but
actually we've not yet found anything
better we've tried like experimental
communitarian stuff of communes all this
kind of whatever
we've tried
um completely doing away with marriage
and basically ending up with huge
numbers of single mothers who are
dependent on the state to some degree
none of these have worked
you know if I my view is and if it's a
defeaters for you then so be it that
what we actually have to choose from as
a culture are systems that have actually
existed and have actually succeeded in
real life not imagined Alternatives that
have never actually been
tried
we can all design like Society on the
back of an envelope and think that this
would be amazing it's like a classic
sort of undergrad PPS thing to do right
like come up with come up with like the
perfect social system
um and think you can impose it on people
I don't think you can I think actually
what you've really got to choose from is
is a very small and very flawed set of
options now you've said you never very
and yeah about the two Guardians
um do you feel that the left is
welcoming to some of the views because
obviously if you take away like the
bullet points from what you're just
saying I think it would look much more
at home on a conservative thinking
Manifesto do you mean than what you'd
expect it and definitely ready
uh yeah in general I've had I've had
more positive attention from the right
than from the left although I'm not I'm
definitely not
chummy with the like
small state conservatives by any means
and the and the the like the the free
market
end of the the really very libertarian
Wing that conservative parties
absolutely there's trust is not your
person
we'll see she's been making promises on
her
on family taxation which I hope she
lives up to but um yeah I mean that the
I I guess where I'm at politically
nowadays is probably like culturally
right economically left that kind of
quadrant which is a very popular
quadrant among voters yeah I think
that's almost where Boris Johnson was in
2019. I suppose so yeah although he
really needs to read my book
you should send him a copy maybe I
should he's got time in town
um so I'm trying to talk about your new
Ventures so thank them just really do I
wondered have you had any I suppose
figures or movements embrace
some of the arguments you're making in a
way that's made you feel uncomfortable
um just in the sense that we're
obviously talking about how obviously
there's always more nuanced to things
like they can seem so it's
you're not saying as far as I understand
you know everything that came with the
sexual Revolution and some of this
feeling was a bad thing but of course
when you're all talking about something
such as being
pro-marriage uh you know units together
obviously you can attract people who
want to use that argument to advance
their agenda has it been anything like
that
um those groups tend to actually uh get
a bit annoyed with me because they think
I've not been I've think I've not gone
far enough
um it is true that I have had more
generally and more positive reception on
the right than on the left with the
exception of things like very nice
review in The Observer and so on
um
but
I kind of just
I'll take it you know whoever's I mean I
I think that
there is just as much of a misogynist
streak on the right as on the left I
think it's completely even
to be honest you know that I think it's
Andrew Dawkins he said that um
um the right considers women to be
private property the left consider them
to be public property you know there's
I I I really can't put a piece of paper
between between right and left in terms
of like the record on women
um and I do actually think maybe we'll
talk about this in relation to the half
that um
feminism is leaving the left
it's always historically been associated
with the left and to something like
second wave feminism comes out of
um left-wing movements of the 60s
although always in tension always always
conflict on various fronts
um I think now that that isn't I think
increasingly that's not the case and I
think actually it's not that feminism is
joining the right per se I think it's
more that it's slightly orthogonal to
the right the Left Right distinction
um we saw that for instance with all the
conflict over gender recognition acts in
this country which was the reforms were
initially proposed by a conservative
government and then they ended up being
recented by a conservative government as
well you know you had
you had proponents and opponents across
the house there wasn't really a
correlation with party affiliation ditto
with things like newspapers you know you
had the Morning Star being really turfy
and then you had plenty of like
libertarian conservatives who were
really proud of these reforms so I think
that
and what came out of that they're like
Grassroots feminist response to that
which came out of groups like mumsnet
which was very much
um
like I think it's absolutely no
coincidence that mothers are
particularly hostile to the kind of
radical undertrans activism which says
that there are there are no distinctions
between men and women there's biological
sexist construct whatever like if you've
pushed a person out of your vagina you
just you're just not like at home to
that kind of argument
um
and it's I'm really interested to see
where that goes that Grassroots movement
because I I don't think it's going to be
like
singing from the same him sheet as
progressives
on everything now you mentioned your
Think Tank
um so it's the other half
um you founded it recently very
co-founded it and we're we're speaking
in Westminster but the important thing
to Anchor is to get voices outside of
Westminster can you tell us more
so there's a really big goal I mean this
is this is this shouldn't be news to to
most people who follow politics but
there's a there's a gap on all sorts of
things including on feminist issues
between what voters tend to say what
what voters tend to tell pollsters and
what tends to be considered
sort of consensus within Westminster
um
one example I mean one example would be
gender recognition act which was which
was the reforms were pushed by
all sorts of elite voices and you know
Academia media whatever was was was full
of resounding support for this like even
the no debate thing hashtag no debate
you know that the idea that this was
like not even enough discussion whereas
actually we know that that was
absolutely not the position among like
Normie mums
um
it's also true on things like family
policy you know the the standard View
among feminists in Westminster is that
the solution to the problem of
negotiating work and motherhood is more
daycare Universal daycare hours
encouraging women to get back into the
office as quickly as possible
um basically severing the physical link
between mothers and children as quickly
as possible so that women can get back
to work we know that most women don't
want that
and actually the the proportion of
mothers who who consider their career to
be more I mean most women don't have
careers first of all like most women
have jobs
consider their career or their job to be
more important than their than their
family is quite a small minority it is
however by definition a minority who
tend to predominate
in areas in areas of public life where
being a mother being a mother is a
massive disadvantage and mothers will
tend to kind of Fall by the wayside as
time goes by and it becomes impossible
for them to negotiate both roles
simultaneously
um what most women want what most
mothers and fathers tell posters they
want is to be able to have more choice
to spend more time at home and just
maybe work part-time work flexibly take
periods out when their children are
little or you know not necessarily
absent the workplace you know I'm not
I'm really not saying we go back to a
period where women were restricted from
entering public life apart from anything
else I'd be a terrible hypocrite say
that but
this idea that being like a man in every
possible way right imitating the
masculine role whether that being in
terms of sexuality or in terms of
professional life
is the obvious way of improving women's
lives I just don't accept that premise
um I think actually there's a lot to be
said for actually saying that you know
the feminine the domestic the other half
of life
actually has
as much virtue and as it should be
considered as valuable
as the masculine sphere and that the job
of feminism is not just about kind of
breaking down the barriers to give women
access to that sphere it's about
protecting the welfare of women and
their children
more generally do you remember Labor's
pink bus do you remember this one back
when Adam and the band was leader and
Harriet Harman went on the road in a
pink bus to talk about women's issues it
just made me think when you're talking
and everyone went absolutely mental and
was like this is a disgusting version of
like you know patronizing to women what
they want but no I just wonder if you
had any thoughts I completely forgotten
about living yeah I do try really hard
not to sort of have pink too much it was
my only my only request about the book
cover was that it'd not be pink in my
only request about branding for the
other half was that it'll be pink so
focus on women's issues good but just
not pink well just because people make
assumption I personally love the color
pink and will happily wear the color
pink but
um
final question is when we ask everyone
on this podcast which is just what is
the worst advice you've ever been given
whether you took it or just ignored it
straight away
I so I got
um married unusually young I mean I'm
usually young in um
not historically how young are we
talking I got engaged when I was 24 in
marriage when I was 12 years so in like
the 1980s that was completely
that was average but now the average age
of marriage has gone up a lot
um and I had a friend at the time when I
got engaged to my new husband who said
that I was making a terrible error and I
my twenties were for like shagging as
many people as possible
and I did think at the time like oh no
she's right but I obviously didn't obey
her advice
I mean that was my worst piece of advice
well thank you thank you thank you thank
you for joining us today
[Music]